géraldine maillet ce que dans les dîners
mondains vous avez parfois du mal à mu
s'assumer travailler dans tpm paix et
c'est vrai qu'on fait parce qu'on fait
beaucoup de rigolade c'est pas du tout
une fierté pour moi et les gens de la
haute des fois même pas trop fait pas
partie de la haute mais après tout et
non mais j'adore le mélange de genres de
tpm paix et j'adore être avec tous mes
camarades on est tous d'horizons
différents et je n'aurais jamais
rencontré rené sans vous maxime sans
vous et rené n'aurait jamais rencontré
le professeur à oslo non avec géraldine
s'est rencontré il ya deux trois six
autres tombes et ça c'est plus mal ça
s'est mal passé
c'est pas très grave ça peut m'expliquer
et à l'époque il y avait un cabinet
comme bal cd minutes et elle jumeaux
l'un des guides immunocal était pas
question
là c'est les vidéos qu'on fait à midi
avait 5 g
mais moi je lis mes calculs turcotte
tout temps mais qui tu es j'en
connaissais pas attention je rentre à
l'hôtel et bien que vous n'étiez pas
qu'ils aient dit non il me dit c'est la
faveur des dernières yolo manqué malheur
ne met pas le cas mais son mari mais je
sais pas c'était super au grand journal
ses fans tapie qui m'envoie un message
qui vous embrasse un bon pour avoir
cette époque on adore si on vous demande
isabelle de choisir entre un dîner avec
l'équipe de rtl où un dîner avec
l'équipe de tp napper avec qui allez
vous mangez pas avec l'équipe de tpm t
ah oui c'est vrai que l'équipe de rtl il
mange très tôt
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
là le congo fait ça tombe bien on aurait
pu faire le couvre-feu à 17h girondine à
16 heures à 17 heures on est au lit un
non mais c'est vrai on les aime bien
quand même bien des gens sympas là bas
cyril est ce que la onzième saison de
tmp sur à la dernière non johnny se sera
pas du tout du tout du tout la dernière
puisque on est encore là pour trois sont
déjà sûrs et peut-être 4 maxime soi
déclare être en couple depuis un moment
oui peux tu nous donner le prénom de la
personne avec qui tu partages ta vie tu
ne veux pas que je le disais donc je
respecte son choix
c'est un jour j'ai donné le prénom de
quelqu'un avec qui je sortais et elle
n'a pas supporté et elle manage ou un
métier à un âge où un métier un âge
alors 34 ans à 24 ans un métier routier
[Rires]
la communication jeu dans la
communication
mon angoisse parce que je sais que vous
avez donc si un jour je suis fort lucide
elle a vu les prix des mémoires et ouais
si je rappelle très bien et lui 6 am
altiste et emma dernier ne donnait pas
dans notre zoom arrière
rené quelques chroniqueurs vous a le
plus mal accueillie bon j'ai touché j'ai
tout le temps été bien accueilli mais la
plaie jean-michel aussi oui aujourd'hui
ne cessa de ses 22 points moi je moi
j'aime bien mes rôles tous les témoins
que tu crois c'est beaucoup tu m'aimes
européenne et même plus jean michel
onfray combien tu payes et et implants
capillaires 0 c'est un échange de bons
procédés j'ai fait une vidéo pour la
clinique qui a été vue parce que c'est
la deuxième opération la première était
vu 2,5 millions de fois rappelé une
deuxième fois le fait de la pub mais je
pas payer ça vous convient en brenne
façade
c'était entre dix et douze mille euros
comment comptez vous acheter une wii
maintenant j'ai du client que vous avez
fait une émouvante demande en mariage
sur ce plateau
pourrait-on savoir quand fatwa prévu de
passer de la tv 4 on vous dit ça mais je
peux pas vous dire plus ça avance à
grand grand grand rêve elle doit être
[Applaudissements]
les jumelles étaient réfléchis
prenez questions du public quelle
qualité isabelle acte votre femme n'a
pas mais ça ne dit
les pauvres ils répondent après c'est
vrai qu'il a bel et bien commencé à
l'autoritaire bien on a une belle vie la
belle c'est mon ami donc d'accord et
d'eau et bal à isabelle a pris une
claque boys
ok tu ce dossier valérie benaïm toi qui
connais tous les chroniqueurs depuis des
années lequel a pris le plus la grosse
tête
ça peut être un chroniqueur qui n'est
pas là non plus dit la vérité avoir
vraiment très bon vraiment un peu ouais
c'est vrai ils arrivent ils arrivent le
dernier os plaques dans le plat ouais
ouais c'est vrai que sap avait clamé par
le public aimerait sur marquez c'est
vrai mais bon
medidata et dar k mais j'en passe très
très fort derrière l'on regardera si
madame chen notre raymond clément
garantit la question acclamations du
public avant vous crachez sur tvm paix
maintenant vous y travaillez comment
expliquez-vous ce retournement de veste
on va expliquer comme vous m'avez
interpellé en 2017 sur twitter parce que
j'avais critiqué tpm paix mais j'avais
dit très gentiment bien sûr n'a pas fait
la nique et arras
[Applaudissements]
ça s'est très bien passé il avait
demandé à me rencontrer sur paris dont
c'est vrai on s'est rencontré dans une
brasserie vous avez payé du bien et donc
ensuite mais voilà on a continué à se
parler pendant plusieurs mois
j'aime beaucoup et voilà et je pense que
ça se passe bien j'ai appris à vous
connaître j'ai appris à connaître
l'émission j'ai appris à connaître les
chroniques à et j'ai changé d'avis mais
c'est vrai que voilà j'aime bien savoir
pourquoi les jobards ict est vrai que
j'appelle sont gentiment en plus on sait
maintenant franchement et que j'étais
très bien passé attendez je vais pas
dupe attaque et clémence et non pas dans
plus est maintenant vraiment je le dis
on s'adore franchement c'est même
franchement mais je sais que je peux
compter sur moi en plus je sais que
voilà il le sait qu'il peut compter sur
ma vie j'ai vraiment faut pas qu'ils
jugent voilà je viens avec ta qui au
bout du banc
[Rires]
géraldine maillet imaginons qu'au studio
prend feu qu'il faut sauver notre
chroniqueur lequel tu ne sauve pas et
dire là tu peux même être l'animateur tu
peux pas me sauver ce tueur belge vous
sauve pas parce que je sais que vous
êtes tellement fort vous allez réussir
par vous même bien joué et bien joué à
[Applaudissements]
eux non ronnie non c'est bon oui tiens
j'ai à gilles verdez depuis la rentrée
vous êtes beaucoup plus calme est ce que
c'est parce que cyril vous a mis un coup
de pression oui oui vous les raisons
mêmes répond oui le dis honnêtement
la vérité c'est que j'adore qui a mis et
que gilles c'est vraiment un garçon que
j'aime
humainement et que j'aime sur le plateau
et c'est vrai qu'à un moment dans tpm
pechoux dit ouh là ce soir là choix
raconte c'est vrai qu'à un moment il y
avait peu de gens qui étaient vraiment
contre les émissions et séries jean il a
jamais joue un rôle quand il est contre
une émission il le nie mais c'est vrai
que comme c'est un peu le seul à un
moment c'était un peu le seul à gueuler
mais je lui dis c'est vrai donne ton
avis mais donne moi même si tu es le
seul et en fait maintenant ça passe
beaucoup mieux parce que les gens
franchement de disques vous faites une
un début de saison exceptionnel est
vraiment merci à vos bas bravo mon gilet
cain soraya el ketchup au goût pourquoi
peu et dit la vérité qui est le plus
différent devant et derrière la caméra
dans toute la bande des six qui est
celui qui est différent
derrière la caméra et devant dit la
vérité 1 a les mêmes ce qui sent pas la
wii comme dirait gérard louvin kipawa
être fils il aura d'ailleurs gérard
alors qu'ils n'ont le mois
vrai oui c'est maxime ouais ouais ouais
c'est plus des tentes en coulisse coupé
en plateau à travailler un peu de
pression platanor guardian qu'il ya une
question de david barbe et un pote voilà
j'en ai dit qui dit valérie at elle mal
pris la rédac poil et voilà non non non
ça on s'appelle régulièrement avec 6
voilà et franchement en plus on avait
déjà évoqué une éventualité est la
nouvelle émission tmp week-end donc non
non c'est pas alors très bien soirée
avec c'est lui qui est le plus le pareil
en dehors de la caméra qui est le maire
jean michel jazy tellement valérie donné
mais même défaut deux défauts qui vous
insupporte chez un des chroniqueurs
celui n'importe lequel
ouais j'ai dévoré gilles qui voient des
complots tout le temps tout le temps
tout le temps et voilà ça c'est
insupportable
ouais parce qu'il est tout le temps où
c'est noir ou ces blancs ya jamais gris
avec lui ça ses premiers défauts et isa
quand elle radote adacore très bien la
belle elisa vous avez pris un petit
tacle question jean michel toi qui fais
partie des anciens chroniqueurs
quelle nouvelle recrue est un mauvais
choix selon toi elle recrute un mauvais
choix
ça me gêne de le dire parce qu'il n'est
pas là mais j'aimais beaucoup moins
simple et clément h ménages était ma
passion et je trouve qu'ils ont été très
bons pilotes par exemple mais moi il se
trouve le sais pas si c'est la pression
pas non mais quand il est l'émission
commence
eh ben je sais pas si dubaï non il fait
de très bonnes et j'espère que tu vas
revenir avec nouvelle arrive il va se
lâcher va vous cracher à la gueule
tiens isabelle si cyril de barrez ttp
selon vous quels animateurs pourrait
parfaitement lui succéder sincèrement
moi je pense aucun os aucun lien avec
les défoulés qualité c'est à dire qu'il
est à la fulgurance ya peut-être pas non
plus la niaque
non moi je pense sincèrement que si vous
vous arrêtez l'émission s'arrête
sincèrement va écouter dans un verre
d'eau pour l'instant je continue
la raison tient enfin une question dont
je vais pas une dernière question
jean michel maire ou et après j'aurais
deux dernières cayenne dernière question
pour moi qui est très chaude
jean-michel parmi toutes les
chroniqueuses de tpe actuels et passés
laquelle aurais tu aimé pécho le plus ce
sont des fumeuses soeur delphine
wespiser la trouve magnifique rayonnante
brion et mais je lé mac et je respecte
j'aime beaucoup son nom son mec
la motion schnyder roger que j'envoie ce
qui d'ailleurs et voilà mais je vous ai
dit j'ai même guerre roger que ce
n'était pas là
la quadrette mais c'est ça notre force
on vous dit les choses
[Rires]
question pour moi la dernière regarde la
caméra et ils sont durs le public 1 et
donne nous sincèrement la principale
qualité d'arthur de yann barthès et
michel cymes ou là on va se retrouver
lundi à bien n'ont alors pas yann
barthès yann barthès gérer que c'est un
très bon journaliste
moi je crois qu'il fait bien son truc
franchement j'ai rien rencontrera yann
barthès si jamais eu de problème
vraiment et qu'elle barthez
j'ai toujours dit ici j'en ai on n'a pas
de voix là on est on se connaissait pas
ce qui est un canal avant mais je sais
pas tous ces culs donc c'est chaud qui
fait bien son boulot fait bien son taf
michel cymes sa principale qualité
franchement c'est qui il est quand même
mal hein il est malin il arrivait et
arthur jeudi au froid son prénom
voilà